that uh Rubble I can just see some
images now actually the yellow and blue
helmets will be the official recovery
teams
waving to the crowd and illustrating
that this person is still alive at the
golden time for earthquake survival is
long since gone now but on occasion we
are still seeing these images where
people are being brought alive from the
remains of what was once their homes
most people would have been sleeping
when this earthquake hits at about just
after four o'clock and I was saying in
the morning waving at the crowd to say
he's he's fine he's doing okay
many had thought it was turning into
a recovery operation but not for this
man he lives to fight another day being
told by the team that a second person a
second person has been pulled alive from
the wreckage of this apartment building
almost unbelievable more cheers
more celebrations from those that have
been digging for days and days to try to
find anybody that may still be trapped
beneath these mounds of rubble
um
we have stood next to
um several collapsed buildings over the
last few days sadly the rescue workers
despite their best efforts have not been
rewarded by scenes like this but
thankfully another it looks like a lady
this time has been brought out of this
wreckage alive